[Musica]
molto bene molto bene
rinascita chi tema importante no che
tema affascinante
ho sempre amato moltissimo questa parola
anche se il prefisso si presuppone che
qualcosa alla prima non è andata del
tutto bene ciononostante rinascita
proprio in sé qualcosa di
tranquillizzante perché esprimere la
possibilità di una seconda chance di una
terza di una quarta e nel suo vasto no
valore significativo ospita un sacco di
immagini metaforiche dalle più comuni di
quelle di tutti i giorni ne ho lavorato
come una matta un mal di schiena
distrutta
ho fatto una sauna mi sono sentita
rinascere a quelli più esistenziali no
quel rapporto era un inferno
abbiamo sofferto tantissimo ho provato
tanto dolore poi ci siamo lasciati e
dopo col tempo mi sono sentita rinascere
funziona rinascere fa è un bel concetto
funziona è un bel modo di dire ciò
nonostante non posso esprit che
esprimere la mia avversità ai modi di
dire sì perché il modo di dire è il modo
con cui il dire si nasconde dietro una
barricata di vaghezza che esprime in un
modo sbrigativo spesso inesatto
distratto la qualità di un sentimento la
qualità di un emozione la qualità di
un'esperienza no potendoli dignità e
prendendola in qualche modo opaca ma
parliamo
di rinascita
anzi voglio farvi un esempio quando ci
si definisce offesi no è un modo un po
borghese e anaffettivo per non definirsi
feriti io preferisco di gran lunga
definirmi ferita profondamente perché
quella ferita si mostra me in tutta la
sua gravità in tutta la sua importanza
in tutto il suo valore
se preferisco dire ferita e offesa
ma torniamo alla rinascita è una parola
che ho usato tantissimo soprattutto
quando ero delle scelte sì perché quando
sei ragazzi
no non siamo troppo armati per capire e
dare un valore all'esperienza e quindi
si ricorre a un termine così vago per
parlarne ma ora che sono vecchia anche
se faccio molto per non sembrarlo ma lo
sono
beh adesso ho un'urgenza quella di dare
un nome ai sentimenti un nome esatto ai
sentimenti un nome esatto alle emozioni
un nome esatto alle esperienze e
trovarli un luogo esatto nel mio animo
l'esattezza mi convince mi tranquillizza
perché mi fa capire che quel sentimento
quell'esperienza quell'emozione io l'ho
compresa
l'ho accolta e l'ho fatta mia quanto
detesto la vaghezza io amo l'esattezza
in tutto in tutto nelle cose più cretine
anche se ho bisogno di un materasso
voglio che ci siano quelle gauzzi ci si
chiamano materasso mania
no siamo sicuri che le un materasso c'è
più bisogno di una vite o di un bullone
certo non pretendo che esista la fonte
del bullone ma l'esistenza di un
ferramenta mi tranquillizza un'altra mia
fissazione alla stime tria mamma mia una
roba da vecchia proprio l'asti mitri a
due vasi metti su un cammino un punto a
a un punto b che delineano uno spazio
intermedio dove uno volumetto è quello
che vuole la forte di una vecchia
parente una composizione di fiori una
bella festa africana
ecco la signora fuer sta andando fuori
tema no in realtà questo è il mio modo
il materasso la vita e la simmetria per
esprimervi che alla mia età si ha
bisogno di certezze che bisogno di
capire con certezza il proprio sentire i
propri sentimenti e anzi se ha voglia si
ha necessità che ogni sentimento abbia
il suo speculare il suo posto
no rancore perdono levità pesantezza
luminosità oscurità allora in questo mio
delirio senile un po degli opposti dato
per valido il valore della parola
rinascita esiste la parola ri morte
no e io dove la metto la mia testa
africana
qui barcollano le certezze ma per
fortuna tutti noi abbiamo due certezze
nella vita
la nascita e punto a e la morte il punto
b
e nel mezzo c'è una cosa meravigliosa
che è l'esistenza è anche una cosa
ancora più meravigliosa e dare un senso
alla propria esistenza
no signori non si rinasce perché non si
rimuove finché si è in vita si è
costretti ad essere invita a stare
invita a trovare delle esperienze a
provare sentimenti importanti come
rabbia dolore amore amicizia devozione
riconoscenza appartenenza a la vita ci
dà la possibilità di scalzare le nostre
convinzioni e sostituirle con altre più
fresche più solide più vigorose che ci
rappresentano di più in quel momento la
vita ci dà la possibilità di ri crederci
senza rimorchio e rinascite intermedie
tantomeno resurrezioni che è un
privilegio che è stato dato a pochi e
anche difficilmente documentabile trovo
comunque
vi racconto di racconto di me quando ho
perduto il mio amato compagno erben
fuera
era un uomo dolcissimo e molto solido
ben quando lui ha mangiato io mi sono
sentita completamente persa i miei
pensieri erano pieni di morte non non
volevo esistere più
ero così arrabbiata che lui l'avesse
lasciata da sola in questo mondo
ero terrorizzata i miei pensieri erano
di sparire di morire
starei voluto morire ma niente
la vita non mi ha concesso questo lusso
ho dovuto stare in vita in quella vita
nella mia vita e fare i conti con la
perdita del mio amato ma col tempo
proprio grazie al tempo della vita ho
ritrovato la mia stabilità
ho riscoperto il valore delle piccole
cose ho trovato un posto all'amore per
il mio amato erbe nel suo ricordo
non voglio certo convincere nessuno a
non usare più il termine rinascita per
il quale io voglio esprimere tutta tutto
il mio rispetto
soprattutto nel suo valore letterario
poetico evocativo mistico religioso nel
suo valore animico ma vi invito tutte le
volte che vi è possibile scegliere con
cura il nome da dare ai vostri movimenti
interiori ve ne sono di meravigliosi
ritrovarsi riaffacciarsi ritornare
ricostruire e perché no rivoluzionare
concludo esprimendo la mia totale
antipatia per la figura dell'araba
fenice questo c'e laccio agitato
rumoroso esibizionista per
autocombustione trovo anche volgare e
nasce rinasce la cenere il fuoco mamma
mia
un casinista troppo ingombrante da io mi
auspico che questa araba fenice chianti
una volta per tutte schianti grande
anche sì ma anche perché trovi un pò di
pace no no
e se proprio deve rinascere per lo meno
che non lasci troppa cenere in giro
grazie
[Applauso]